Oh Howie Jones here seed potatoes you
know plant them you know seed potatoes
all different times all different kinds
one color the same
like this blue ones for fish but they're
really good they look good with salmon
Cod these are elephant garlic's
their big garlic and throw them in round
again I've got a lot of borrowers anyway
put it in this should be fun these red
potatoes they look good these look
awesome nice I see potatoes the
fingerlings are cool no that's original
that's a yeah yeah yeah
oh but in the Sun a little bit they're
green you don't want to eat that ones
what the plat that ones but there's all
different kinds here here's another
here's some more I think there's a bad
seed potato stuff happens yeah there it
is Oh too bad you gotta get it out there
go
they didn't get a chance to to grow but
that's okay
all these will buy